I really want to start with a sincere
congratulations on the movie I thought
you did such a great job with his
material and with the film um the thing
that I found fascinating is that his
story is so incredible that you there's
so many parts of his of his story that
could be a movie how much uh uh talk a
little bit about focusing on this part
of his life when there's so many other
chapters too well that's that wasn't my
job I was it's it's not it's not a
miniseries it's it's it's a film and so
I wanted to start at the where at the
point where I think there's a there's
where the country is confronting itself
in an extraordinary way just in the
sense that that it you know it's Brown
versus Board of Education has been in
existence for quite some time and the
south is just pretending it doesn't
exist uh and so there's a sense of
activism and a sense of responsibility
it's also at a time where many people
have been engaged in the Civil Rights
mov for quite some time especially
focusing on nonviolence and that's not
resulting in change so they're beginning
to consider whether or not they need to
take a more aggressive point or more Upp
point of view a more segregated point of
view and B who has been always out as a
as as in terms of a 1963 definition of
an out gay man you know there are there
are things that that the FBI in
particular have dug up about him and are
threatening so it feels like there's a
press there's pressure coming from from
all different directions plus they're
trying to pull off the world's this
country's largest peaceful protest in 8
weeks so that pressure Dynamic him being
tested him grooming a whole generation
of incredible young people to be smart
active and committed to making their
country better all of that seemed to be
the perfect equation to play around with
instead of he was born and then he grew
up and then he went to school and then
you know blah blah blah so the thing
that's so crazy which I I don't think
people realize is pulling off the March
in8 weeks no social media no cell phones
I mean it's it's really it's it's you
would think it would take a year to pull
this thing off so can you sort of talk
about that aspect of how incredible he
was just to be able to do this well it's
like even people who had issues with him
everyone connected to the Civil Rights
Movement knew that he was the most
brilliant organizer and he had that
brain who did not skip or miss any
detail and he trained his team of kids
to think that the same way there was a
there's a there was a speech in the in
the film which isn't there anymore in
which he talked about every night I want
you to begin go from the beginning to
the end of the March and think about
every single detail and think about
everything that you think you've solved
and think about those spaces after those
things that you think you've saw and see
if there's something you're missing and
and what he was instructing them to do
is what he did every sing SLE night I
believe was going over the details over
and over and over and making sure every
single thing is done including getting
mayor Wagner to alter the subway
schedule you know for for a rush hour
schedule for early in the morning so
everybody could get their buses so they
could get there it's just no detail went
went went without him scrutinizing and
picking at it and making sure everything
flowed brilliantly you you bring up uh
editing uh I love the editing process
because it where it's where it all comes
together so talk a little bit about how
the film changed in the editing room
perhaps in ways you didn't expect uh
there certain it was very interesting
other people it's like other people had
relationships like a Phil Randol had
there was a moment where where his wife
was more involved and and and by and her
danced together but it became but that
became extraneous because it was about a
Phil randol's relationship with buer and
that kept on happening the kids told the
story about
about how they got involved in activism
and that scene went away and one of the
most interesting things that that left
was B spoke at the March on Washington
he he read The List of Demands and and I
and it was in this film for a very very
long time but I ended up eliminating it
because it was a it wasn't his language
it was just a a list and B it didn't
have a kind of poetry and so the most
poetic moment comes at the end him
picking up the trash and him continuing
to do what he does what what he what he
had has had always done which is commit
to making whatever he was connected to
better and stronger and clearer and in
this case cleaner one of the things that
I am waiting for Netflix to do because
they can do anything is offer deleted
scenes on the on Netflix or offer extras
in a way that they sometimes don't do is
that something you've talked to them
about because I'd love to see Coleman do
you know what I mean like I'd love to
see some of these scenes No no I haven't
talked to him about that maybe I will
thank you I'm just I'm just throwing
that out there absolutely you know and
obviously listen I have to touch on this
going to probably be my last thing but I
have to touch on Coleman's amazing
performance he's so brilliant in this uh
can you sort of talk about working with
him in crafting this performance and
what it was like on set when you needed
something to be tweaked and you know
what I mean just working with Coleman
well I work with him the same way I work
with him on Mary the way same way I work
with every other actor we have a twoe
rehearsal period which is spent you know
forming relationships not not just
between me but between the the
characters between Tom between Elias his
two love interests uh with with Ella and
which was played by arj McDonald and so
it was it was about building foundations
and and building textur so that by the
time we started shooting those
relationships had a sense of History had
a sense of uh of of of of
of zones that were safe and zones that
were violated in a good storytelling way
so it was all just a part of the process
and and you and and you work to try to
build a sense of safety so that the
actors can be as vulnerable so that
therefore the impact of what they are
receiving from the other actor magnifies
their work and that's what happened when
when you have you know scene with
Coleman and Audrey McDonald or you have
a scene with Coleman and aamine or a
Philip Rand the power Dynamics and the
intensity of the performances of his
performance meeting their performances
and their performance meeting his
creates something that was really
combustible and and exciting and I think
uh very fragile on that note I got to go
I'm just going to say again congrats on
a great film thank you very
much